und wie alt bist du 16 aber nicht alles
selber bezahlt oder darin ganz ganz hart
arbeiten und diese mit den mülleimer
gefunden
die jacke hat 1700 euro 1700 euro
sie war bei 12
willkommen beim neuen video leute ich
hab euch geht's gut man sieht mir
wahrscheinlich an ich bin voll fertig
gut jetzt geht es eigentlich wieder ich
bin gerade in berlin also noch in berlin
und wir hatten ja gestern fußballturnier
von adidas nahmen viele verschiedenen
youtuber mitgespielt auch echt cool aber
auch sehr anstrengend ja darum sollte
aber eigentlich gar nicht gehen
und zwar so seit längerer zeit ihr kennt
bestimmt alle diese videos ja wieviel
ist dein outfit wird irgendwie immer
wenn ich auf youtube hier
ich hoffe meine startseite irgend so ein
video und natürlich habe ich mir auch
mal das eine oder andere angeschaut ich
meine diese videos na okay klar kann es
auch sein dass die youtuber gezielt
leute wählen oder leute ansprechen die
halt irgendwas teures an haben und dann
halt nur die ansprechen aber in diesen
videos sind einfach nur menschen drin
die outfits an haben die 3000 euro wert
sind und das beste ist dann immer dann
kommt ein zwölfjähriger ok kurzstopp
bevor wir weitermachen schaue ich mir
erst mal ein video davon an auf dem
turnier gestern waren aber auch ziemlich
viele youtube die ich selber mal gefragt
habe wie teuer denn ihr outfit ist das
ganze jetzt nicht so auf die ernste art
und weise sich hört gleich sehen also
sagen ich hab noch 25 minuten da muss
jetzt ein zimmer heraus ich habe mir
diese kopfhörer hier gefunden okay leute
fangen wir an
sozusagen 4 605 606 euro
der fokus im areal sein okay okay ich
finde das irgendwie voll traurig so man
mit 12 13 okay aber der typ ist das
schlimm
22 23 und man merkt ja so voll wie er
sich so pusch dass er so ein krasses
outfit und jetzt mal abgesehen von der
unterhosen für 120 euro haben die leute
zu viel geld wo das hier habe ich
gesponsert bekommen das t shirt auch
kostet vielleicht rudy 40 euro t shirt
20 euro rose hab ich auch umsonst
bekommen kostet im shop 30 euro gut ich
habe jetzt keine schuhe an und sagen wir
haben 95 euro gekostet bin ich bei nicht
mal 200 euro
und sie trotzdem cool aus 250.000 selbst
wenn meine eltern noch so reich werden
weil er hier ist ja höchstens 18 19
der wird wohl doch nicht job haben
wollen eben 11.000 euro für eine rolex
und 250 euro für ein t-shirt bezahlen
können liga verkauft sich denn für
200.000 t shirt
sich und die 297 große 490 ohne witz
lassen sich das doch bitte mal in den
kommentaren wissen schreibt eure meinung
dazu findet ihr das normal dass man
guckt euch mal dieses bild an zwölf 1390
euro
jungs wie ihr euch selbst wäre ja noch
so viel geld hat eine hose kaufen für
500 euro dafür kriegst du zwölf hosen
okay leute hier noch mal kurz ein
anderes video 130 200 hose sage ich
jetzt mal ich weiß dass die 820 5 t
shirt alt ok wirklich von 50 auf 120
seiten sage ich jetzt jacke einfach
gerade vom bett
natürlich tragen originale sachen mit 12
und wegen sowas werden dann kinder in
der schule gemobbt weil die zwölfjährige
von ihren eltern outfits im web von 5000
euro kriegen okay leute letzte szene
hört nightliner original 150 bitte
nochmal neu
beim goethe 1500
bald war er sagt 150 dann sagt sie nein
du musst doch null dran hängen 1500 ein
bisschen ein bisschen weniger 800 ohne
wird es gut die sind jetzt schon ein
bisschen älter aber ich verstehe nicht
nur mit der katze den auto kaufen von
gut 14 euro gekostet funktioniert ok
bevor ich mich jetzt weiter aufträge ich
habe ein paar youtuber gefragt was sie
denn so tragen wie teuer das ist und ein
paar zuschauer waren auch da nimmt das
auf keinen fall zu ernst es war von
meiner seite oft nur spar reales co
fangen wir bei der kepler soll ich jetzt
beginnt schon so cap 25 viele rudi 75
jeans 80
was waren die 320 und meine uhr 1616
aber nicht aus da ich selber bezahlen
oder da ganz ganz hart arbeiten
toni ist meine eigene marketing blogs
sowie sichert
papa war glaub ich auch irgendwie hin
dass circa 70 airbus 180 180 nur sie war
glaube ich
2500 euro was geht wir haben jetzt hier
wer bis zu 1200 noch mal aufgenommen
am 20
ja
rechtlich okay
120 flugzeuge oder wenn eltern
ja dann haben wir jetzt noch farben
farben große jagd
ich habe gerne beschenken
sonne natur
ich glaube 190 oder was keine ruhe
von monika braun
okay wir haben es hier keine haare
werden 80 gekostet sieben stunden muss
erwarten möchte der
1320 euro
diese mülleimer gefunden
die jacke hat 1700 euro aber es ist die
mittlerweile um die 10.000 2007 habe
wollte ich mir auch immer du willst du
fertig bist abkaufen
sobald das mit 5840 950 hat das gekostet
weil es ganz speziell
und dass hier was ist das genau so dass
die hose oberteil
dann kann es ein bisschen zu pushen und
ich schon auf die schule hat es kommt
erst noch die socken
die socken diesen auch von anders
limitiert von den socken gibt es nur
zehn stück freunde die socken hat wieso
404 sorgten leute die schule
die schuhe haben mieter nicht hoffen
4000 leute jetzt haben wir hier luca
beiden schalke habe ich von einem freund
geklaut keine ahnung
250 so armani uhr nur wieviel 400 400
der motivation das ist 12 jahre gibt
hier nur die position die sie es nicht
doch ein risiko 48 15 uhr tv geklaut ich
weiß nicht anzahl an die ferien zu
kaufen so 500 ganz kurz aber nur alex du
ich wollte mal fragen wie wer sich also
machen wir mal ein pulli
napoli 15 uhr am anfang und untergang
wir haben ein rucksack
limitiert 700 euro combo sachen die ganz
normal mit armband und das auch noch ein
armband habe ich im retail gekauft 600
euro vorteil die wehrleute er auf jeden
fall weiter hose auch limitiert von
adidas
das ist jetzt die meere
der hose 400 euro für das damals noch
chef von adidas ads.etr 12 euro oder 50
euro künftig und schuhe
richtig gar nicht mal so 150 der 700
euro arbeiten zwölf wenn euch das video
gefallen hat last auf jeden fall nach
oben da morgen gibt es auch wieder ein
cooles neues video und morgen morgen
wird das iphone verlor ich weiß auf
jeden fall wieder nach hause zu meinen
eltern schreibt auf jeden fall mal bitte
eure meinung zu dem ganzen thema mit
diesem outfit ich trage so und so viel
du trägst nur soundsoviel ich bin geil
als du so kommt es meiner meinung nach
zumindest fast immer überall so schreibt
eure meinung gerne in die kommentare was
das studium ab und wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder haut rein